[Applaudissements]
trembler mortel
Pluton en ce moment est en train de
sortir de la constellation du Sagittaire
pour entrer dans celle du Capricorne
cet événement céleste aura des
implications néfastes sur chacun d'entre
vous tenez vous le dit
par ailleurs la terre et le centre de
l'univers
elle est plate
elle ne tourne pas sur elle-même
vous en doutez
je vais faire devant vous une expérience
qui prouve que la Terre ne tourne pas
attention ça va être rapide
3 2 1
[Applaudissements]
si la Terre tournait évidemment j'aurais
dû tomber à côté du rond rouge facile
la science contemporaine a heureusement
des méthodes nouvelles et prouvées plus
rationnaire avec une méthode plus carrée
et notamment la science à une méthode
objective réfutable reproductible
universelle pour comprendre le monde
donc l'astrologue magicien qui est
derrière moi a sorti tout un tas de
balises évidemment il n'y a pas
d'endroits privilégier dans l'univers
donc la terre n'est pas au centre de
l'univers même si on peut changer de
référentiel la terre est bien ronde
voilà les complotistes peuvent aller se
rhabiller et la terre tourne bien sur
elle-même ne vous laissez pas avoir par
des démonstrations fallacieuses gardez
votre esprit critique en effet quand
vous êtes dans un train à vitesse rapide
quand vous buvez un café le café ne
s'explose pas sur votre figure vous êtes
entraîné et la terre ici nous entraîne
voilà relativité galiléenne que l'on
connaît depuis plusieurs siècles
alors la science permet de répondre à
plusieurs types de questions quand je
dis la science ce sont les sciences
naturelles expérimentales de santé
exacte humaine et social parce que
toutes les sciences nous permettent de
comprendre le monde de l'expliquer du
mieux qu'on peut de nos sociétés
jusqu'au confins de l'univers en somme
du Big Bang au Big Band
alors la science permet de répondre à
certaines questions comme comment avoir
de bonnes relations avec sa belle-mère
ou ses ados à la maison quelle est
l'origine de la vie comment les
molécules se développent alors plutôt
dans mon rayon les questions qui
m'intéressent sont par exemple la
suivante que je vais détailler
aujourd'hui devant vous quelle relation
y a-t-il entre matière noire dans
l'univers énergie sombre dans l'univers
et une pizza
pour commencer je vais vous indiquer
comment les scientifiques voient
l'histoire scientifiques de l'univers
alors cette histoire de l'univers elle
ne sort pas de la tête de quelqu'un avec
un modèle farfelu elle provient de
mesures
ultra précises d'un côté nous allons
avec nos satellites notamment et nos
télescopes de l'autre côté des modèles
et des observations très précises et les
deux se défient donc les modèles qui
résistent sont passés par un crible
extrêmement étroit et fin en particulier
le modèle du Big Bang dont je vais
parler aujourd'hui est le meilleur
modèle dont nous disposions pour décrire
toute l'histoire de l'Univers alors ce
modèle n'est pas parfait il y a beaucoup
de problèmes on essaie de s'en départir
on le défi mais c'est un peu comme le
sparadrap du capitaine Haddock qui nous
colle à une colle à la main on n'arrive
pas à s'en départir c'est le meilleur
dont on dispose le modèle cosmologique
du Big Bang c'est un peu comme
l'histoire de la chanson hôtel
California des Eagles on essaie de la
quitter on y arrive pas
c'est pas welcome to the Hotel
California welcome to le modèle lambda
CDM du Big Bang
alors pour résumer cette histoire de
l'univers je vais utiliser le calendrier
cosmique on va résumer toute l'histoire
de l'univers très virgule 79 milliards
d'années plus ou moins 0,17 % merci la
science et on va résumer ça en une année
civile 365 jours le Big Bang a lieu le
1er janvier à 0 heure et aujourd'hui
nous sommes le 31 décembre à minuit je
serai assisté de mes chers étudiants
Rayana étudiante en licence à
l'Université Paris Châtelet Yanis a
centrale shoplec de l'université
Paris-Saclay et Dan doctorant en
astrophysique alias à Liège c'est Paris
Saclay
ça va aller très vite mesdames messieurs
vous allez avoir l'histoire de l'univers
en quelques minutes attention les yeux 3
2 1 c'est parti premier janvier le Big
Bang intervient jaillissement incroyable
d'énergie dans tout l'Univers suivi
immédiatement de l'inflation cosmique
une expansion ultra accélérée et ultra
courte qui projette sur des échelles
cosmologiques d'un film fluctuation
quantique dit nano seconde après tout
l'hydrogène de l'univers est synthétisé
c'est à dire que toute l'eau qui a dans
cette bouteille dans nos corps dans les
océans partout de l'univers et
synthétiser lors de la nucléosynthèse
primordiale dynamo seconde après 15
minutes après minuit le fond
cosmologique jaillit dans l'univers
c'est la première lueur de l'univers qui
fait que la nuit n'est pas noire alors
que l'univers a 3000 degrés nous
continuons en janvier vous êtes
l'échelle va s'agrandir le 9 janvier
nous détectons actuellement les galaxies
les plus lointaines et les premières
galaxies jamais observées dans l'univers
on sait pas trop comment elles se sont
développées mais on imagine que c'est
entre le premier et le 9 janvier de
manière évidente 26 janvier
c'est la fin de l'Aube cosmique le début
de la réalisation de l'univers qui est
entièrement réalisé par les premières
étoiles et les premiers croisards nous
arrivons ensuite en février il se passe
rien en mars le 15 mars notre Voie
lactée est formée elle a commencé j'ai
noté hein le 21 j'ai pas raté le 21 le
21 janvier la Voie Lactée commence à se
former et finissent se former le 15 mars
en plusieurs fusions successives elle a
pris du temps vous voyez deux mois et à
la mi-mars il se passe surtout quelque
chose d'extraordinaire dans l'univers
c'est le maximum de formation stellaire
dans l'univers quasiment toutes les
étoiles qui existent dans l'hiver sont
formés à cet instant là on appelle ça le
midi cosmique c'est un feu d'artifice
permanent et c'est un peu comme dans un
champ où il y aurait une explosion de
coquelicots de manière simultanée avril
mais juin il ne se passe rien la matière
noire continue de se condenser d'amener
les barillons avec elle c'est à dire la
matière ordinaire pour former encore des
galaxies juin il se passe rien alors
l'expansion de l'univers comme une
calzone la pizza vous avez compris qu'on
continue de croître moi juillet premier
événement très important qui arrive dans
l'univers l'expansion de l'Univers qui
était jusque la relativement tranquille
se met à accélérer pour les physiciens à
points du facteur d'échelle devient
positive août il se passe rien en
vacances on continue en septembre le 2
septembre formation du soleil du système
solaire et de la terre le 21 septembre
apparition de la vie dans les
océans
29 septembre Lucas dernier ancêtre
commun universel c'est-à-dire le dernier
organisme duquel tout le vivant se met à
diverger jusqu'à aujourd'hui octobre
rien novembre rien les galaxies ont une
se former les trous noirs les molécules
la vie dans le dans l'océan et pour
descendre on va utiliser une échelle
logarithmique une échelle qui étire le
temps puisque vous allez voir il se
passe beaucoup de choses première
semaine de décembre rien
bah vit dans l'océan deuxième semaine de
décembre rien
17 décembre la vie sort des océans pour
atteindre la vie terrestre semaine de
Noël va quand il se passe rien
29 décembre rien vacances aussi 30
décembre 12h30 un astéroïde frappe la
planète Terre et détruit notamment
l'essentiel des dinosaures 31 décembre
22h15 à Paris Sion de l'espèce Homo sur
terre
23h45 apparition de l'homo sapiens
dommage pour la terre 23 heures 59 nos
ancêtres peignent la grotte de Lascaux
23 heures 59 minutes 55 secondes le
mathématicien grec Euclide publie ses 13
volumes de géométrie qu'on utilise
encore aujourd'hui
59 minutes 59 secondes début de la
Renaissance naissance de Blaise Pascal
et de toute l'histoire que l'on connaît
depuis à peu près 400 ans
23h59 minutes 59 secondes 78 centièmes
découvert de l'expansion de l'Univers 79
centièmes découvertes qu'il y a 6 fois
plus de matière dans l'univers que de la
matière visible c'est la matière noire
86 centièmes on découvre le rayonnement
du fond cosmologique qui a été émis
[Musique]
à minuit 15 au tout début de l'univers
et on a découvert ça et on l'observe et
enfin 94 centièmes découvert de
l'expansion accélérée de l'univers et
hop nous sommes aujourd'hui c'est pas
beau la science merci aux étudiants
alors nous savons beaucoup de choses de
manière scientifique on l'a vu néanmoins
on ne sait pas tout et c'est là que on a
besoin d'astrophysicienne et
d'astrophysiciens pour essayer de mieux
comprendre le monde et de comprendre
cette matière noire et cette énergie
sombre alors pour y arriver je vais
évoquer avec vous la manière qu'on fait
pour mesurer cette matière noire et
cette énergie sombre
et donc pour cela nous allons utiliser
le camembert cosmique un prêt le
calendrier cosmique le camembert
cosmique tout va bien le camembert
cosmique traduit la composition de
l'univers à une certaine échelle pour
être précis parce qu'il y a des gens
dans la salle très précis la densité
d'énergie mais j'irai pas dans ces
détails là si on est à l'échelle du
système solaire la composition du
système solaire est entièrement composé
d'atomes traditionnels les barillons on
appelle un astrophysique la matière
comme vous et moi on a l'habitude pas de
souci pas de matière pas de trucs
bizarres c'est normal on est dans un
régime bien cadré si on va plus loin à
l'échelle de notre Voie Lactée à peu
près 100 000 années-lumière on se rend
compte que la matière baryonique les
atomes deviennent minoritaires ça on
mesure très précisément
ce qui est majoritaire dans la Voie
Lactée qu'on ne voit pas c'est la
matière noire c'est une matière qui
gravite mais qui ne rayonne pas si on va
encore plus loin à l'échelle de
l'univers on fait une moyenne sur des
millions voire des milliards
d'années-lumière on se rend compte que
la matière baryonique la matière
ordinaire ne compose que 5% du contenu
densité énergie de l'univers la
composition de l'univers à peu près un
quart de matière noire et la grande
majorité quasiment 70% cette énergie
sombre cette énergie sombre qui provoque
l'expansion accélérée de l'univers comme
une sorte de pression qui pousse les
murs et qui poussent les galaxies les
plus lointaines alors comment on fait
quand on est arrivé là on est un petit
peu gêné parce qu'on sait pas ce que
c'est que la matière noire ni l'énergie
sombre
c'est un peu comme si vous avez une
pizza
mais que vous ne voyez que les olives
pas grave mais que vous sentez que toute
la pizza est là frustrant et excitant
l'univers c'est comme ça on sait on sent
qu'il y a tout le reste on peut pas le
manger mais il y a les olives
alors comment faisons-nous les galaxies
sont nos amis parce que les galaxies qui
sont des ensembles de matière noire et
de et de matières baryonique trace
parfaitement la masse dans l'univers et
sa dynamique à votre gauche je vais y
arriver vous avez une image d'un amas de
galaxies donc la galaxie sont visibles
avec la matière baryonique mais en fait
les galaxies traces la présence de
matière sombre de matière noire qui
était invisible mais qui est
concomitante qui est corrélée à la
présence de galaxies donc il suffit
d'observer les galaxies pour voir où il
y a de la matière noire et à droite
on étudie les galaxies pour étudier
l'expansion de l'Univers qui s'accélère
vous avez compris en mesurant à la fois
l'agrégation des galaxies mais aussi
leur vitesse d'éloignement on voit sur
ce schéma la vitesse le décalage va le
rougeft en anglais qui permet de mesurer
cette dynamique de l'univers alors plus
précisément comment on fait pour la
matière noire c'est finalement assez
simple la matière noire c'est un peu
alors c'est pas un pizzaïolo c'est pas
c'est la matière noire c'est un verre de
vin géant c'est un verre de vin géant
alors transparent avec de l'eau un pas
de vin désolé qui brouille les images
d'arrière-plan comme sur cette image
donc sur l'image des galaxies que vous
voyez vous voyez peut-être des galaxies
rouges qui sont un petit peu recourbés
elles sont pas recourbées comme ça
naturellement si leur image qui est
recourbée à cause de la présence de
matière noire sur la ligne de visée là
où on regarde comme elle est noire qu'on
la voit pas elle génère des effets
gravitationnels de temps de distorsion
comme un verre de vin donc matière noire
égale vers de vin transparent géant ça
va pour l'énergie sombre c'est là qu'on
prend notre pizzaïolo géant dans
l'univers il faut imaginer l'univers
comme un espace-temps à quatre
dimensions ça on y arrive facilement
évidemment et le c'est un espace-temps
qui se dilate un peu comme la pâte à
pizza avant qu'elle passe dans le four
et qu'elle est tournée par le pizzaïolo
et vous imaginez les galaxies qui sont
les grains de farine qui sont au dessus
donc vous voyez bien que la distorsion
l'extension de l'univers n'affecte pas
les petits grains de farine les galaxies
vivent leur vie tranquillement elles
sont juste éloignées les unes des autres
par cette pression négative qui pousse
les murs en quelque sorte donc cette
énergie sombre distors la métrique la
géométrie de l'univers et en mesurant
très précisément à la fois l'agrégation
des galaxies d'une part leur vitesse
d'expansion d'autre part on arrive à
reconstruire le les effets de l'énergie
même si on ne sait pas ce que c'est
alors à partir de là les scientifiques
astrophysiciens en particulier doivent
être créatifs et opiniâtre pour essayer
de vraiment voir là je vous ai donné les
méthodes mais maintenant comment on fait
vraiment et ben comme on est créatif
opiniâtre qu'on ne lâche rien d'ailleurs
nous avons cette nous partageons cette
caractéristique avec les artistes alors
même si la démarche artistique est
scientifique ont des différences les
scientifiques et les artistes partagent
de nombreuses méthodes communes et en
tout cas la créativité et le fait de
rien lâcher donc on va construire un
nouveau télescope pour observer ces deux
effets dark malheur dark energy donc
matière noire énergie sombre
d'habitude on veut un plus grand
télescope pour donner des images
extraordinaires comme celle du James web
télescope que nous avons sous les yeux
énormes télescopes ultra complexe mais
là
nous les Européens on est rusé futé on
va pas faire un télescope plus grand on
va faire un télescope plus petit
et c'est pas seulement parce qu'on
manque de budget
c'est parce qu'on optimise à l'extrême
nos instruments vous voyez le satellite
Euclide mon bébé enfin on est 2000 à
pouvoir dire ça scientifique dans la
Communauté européenne scientifique c'est
un merveilleux satellite qui permet
d'observer ses effets de matière noire
et d'énergie sombre alors Euclide A3
points magiques le premier point magique
de Clide c'est l'endroit où il est il
est au point de la grange L2 du système
Terre-Soleil c'est-à-dire qu'il a quatre
fois la distance Terre-Lune en 1900000
km de nous à un endroit où les images
sont
ultra stables comme le Jedi d'ailleurs
même endroit le deuxième point magique
de la mission spatiale Euclide ce sont
les scientifiques
et les super ordinateurs qui permettent
de traiter des quantités de données
littéralement astronomiques des données
exquises qui nous permettront de traiter
automatiquement ces millions de galaxies
de manière automatique et enfin la
troisième et dernière magie active ce
sont ces caméras ces détecteurs le côté
sensible pas seulement pour faire des
selfies alors justement pour faire des
selfies vous utilisez un smartphone on
va parler de des détecteurs et le
détecteur de votre smartphone à la
taille d'un demi timbre poste à peu près
la taille d'un angle nous on science et
en astrophysique spatiale en particulier
on utilise des télescopes dans l'espace
et le télescope spatial Hubble qui a
fourni des images extraordinaires depuis
quelques décennies faites c'est super
belles images avec un détecteur qui est
de la taille d'une carte de visite
16 mégapixels à peu près image
extraordinaire
le jet de blessty dont on a vu une image
à une caméra infrarouge extraordinaire
c'est à dire qui a la taille d'une
tablette de chocolat
30 millions de pixels vous avez les
images de folie qui a fait
et ben ça c'est la rigolade par rapport
à ce que va faire Euclide
ce que fait oxyde Euclide envoie la plus
grande caméra infrarouge jamais envoyée
dans l'espace c'est l'Europe qui le fait
deux tablettes de chocolat
66 millions de pixels et le clou du
spectacle la caméra visible
600 millions de pixels mesdames et
messieurs la taille d'une boîte de pizza
pour la caméra visible de clean
taille réelle des détecteurs nous sommes
seuls et insignifiants dans l'espace
comme le montre cette image de la
planète Terre vue depuis la planète Mars
vous voyez un tout petit pixel
nous sommes également insignifiants dans
le temps vous avez vu le calendrier
cosmique
ou l'espèce humaine n'arrive que le 31
décembre dans la soirée Blaise Pascal
disait il y a eu une seconde dans le
calendrier cosmique le silence éternel
de ces espaces infinis mes frais alors à
nous de donner du sens à ce silence et
cette insignifiance
à nous de protéger la Terre et tout le
vivant unique jusqu'à nouvel ordre dans
un univers dominé par la matière noire
et l'énergie sombre et à nous de ne pas
être effrayé comme Pascal mais au
contraire de lever avec méthode
créativité délexation jubilation
excitation les tous derniers mystères de
l'univers merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]